- HERE'S TO HAVING
NOTHING TO CELEBRATE.
- ACTUALLY,
TODAY'S MY BIRTHDAY.
- LIKE I SAID,
NOTHING TO CELEBRATE!
- HEY, WHERE'S MALLOY?
- EH, HE COULDN'T BE HERE.
HE GOT TIED UP.
- I'M GOING
TO GET WOODY FOR THIS.
OH, GOD!
WHY ARE YOU LOOKING AT ME
LIKE THAT?
[dog grunts]
THAT IS AN ODD PLACE
TO KEEP YOUR LIPSTICK.
- WHAT'S THE MATTER, BUDDY?
ARE YOU STILL BUMMED
ABOUT YOUR
EPISODE OF INTERVENTION?
- STEVE, WE'RE HERE
BECAUSE WE ALL LOVE YOU.
BUT YOU'VE GOT
TO STOP JIZZING INSIDE US.
- I'M SORRY.
IT JUST FEELS SO GOOD.
- FEELS GOOD? I'M STIFF
AS A BOARD, YOU FREAKY BASTARD!
- NAH, IT'S ETHEL.
YOU KNOW HOW MUCH I LIKE HER,
BUT SHE WON'T GIVE ME
THE TIME OF DAY.
NOW SHE'S DATING
THE CEO OF SKYMALL.
WHAT DOES HE HAVE THAT I DON'T?
- TELEPHONE SHOES?
- YOU'RE RIGHT.
I DON'T STAND A CHANCE.
- STEVE, YOU GOT TO GET WOMEN
WHEN THEY'RE DOWN.
THAT'S WHAT I DO, LITERALLY.
I GET LIFE ALERT
CALLS FORWARDED TO MY PHONE.
[cell phone beeps]
- I'VE FALLEN,
AND I CAN'T GET UP!
- SEE IF YOU CAN SLIP
YOUR PANTIES OFF.
I'LL BE THERE IN A MINUTE.
- IT MAY LOOK LIKE AN ORDINARY
FAN-COOLED SOLAR SAFARI HAT,
BUT IT'S ALSO A LITTER BOX.
[cat meows]
SKYMALL!
- THAT'S AMAZING!
I WAS JUST TELLING A FRIEND
THAT I WISH I HAD A HAT
THAT A CAT COULD SHIT IN.
- SKYMALL!
- LISTEN, I KNOW WE'VE ONLY
BEEN ON A COUPLE OF DATES,
BUT I SEE A REAL FUTURE FOR US.
- I THOUGHT YOU MIGHT SAY THAT.
THAT'S WHY I GOT YOU THIS.
- [gasps] OH, MY GOD!
THE ANSWER IS YE--
- IT'S THE WORLD'S SMALLEST
WHITE NOISE MACHINE.
- WHAT?
BUT WHAT ABOUT US?
- WE'RE DONE.
I'M NOT READY TO SETTLE DOWN.
BUT YOU CAN SET THIS
TO HEAVY RAIN
TO MASK THE SOUND
OF YOUR TEARS.
- YOU'RE BREAKING UP WITH ME?
[rain pattering]
- SKYMALL!
- GIVE ME THAT!
- STEVE, NOW'S YOUR CHANCE.
ETHEL'S LOWER
THAN ABE VIGODA'S LEFT NUT.
- HER NEXT BOTTLE'S ON ME.
- NO, I'LL CALL YOU,
I PROMISE.
WE JUST [bleep] IN THE BATHROOM.
I'M OUT!
- ARE YOU SURE
YOU'RE OKAY TO DRIVE?
- ARE YOU SURE YOU'RE OKAY TO
MIND YOUR OWN GODDAMN BUSINESS?
I'M FINE.
YOU'RE DOING GOOD, JOHNSON.
JUST KEEP IT BETWEEN THE LINES.
[water bubbling]
OH, CRAP. MALLOY, QUICK!
GET BEHIND THE WHEEL!
MALLOY!
AH!
I THOUGHT RED MEANT STOP!
[rousing music]